"Please pardon the interruption. Attention
all students and staff. Please initiate internal
lockdown procedure at this time. I repeat.
Please initiate internal lockdown procedure
at this time."
Hello, and welcome to Al Dente Creepypasta,
horror stories cooked to perfection with a
splash of red sauce. My name is CZ and I will
be your server, this episode. Break is now
over which means it’s time to get back to
Creepy Clown School Lockdown. Let’s dig
right in.
I had been waiting all year for the floor
hockey unit in gym. This year I was out for
blood. There's this kid at my school, Callum,
who thinks he's just the greatest thing that
ever happened to any of us. He plays on a
traveling ice hockey team, so every year when
we get to the hockey unit, he single handedly
outclasses everyone. But that's not enough
for Callum. Oh no, he has to show off, use
all his fancy little tricks. His team wins
every single game and he makes it look easy,
like he's not even interested in trying. As
if his cocky attitude wasn't already a good
enough reason for me not to like him, the
girls just swoon over him, and of course,
he acts like he doesn't care.
Well, me and my friend Geo got tired of being
effortlessly shown up by this pretty-boy,
so we've practicing in his driveway just about
every free day we get. We may not know any
of his fancy little tricks, but I think we're
physically on a level to compete. To add motivation,
there's a girl I like named Kelsey in our
gym class, so I couldn't afford to be embarrassed
by Callum if I go all out.
On our first day of floor hockey, we were
broken up into 8 teams. I led my team to three
undefeated matches before it was time to face
Callum's team, who was also undefeated at
the time. My heart was racing as I walked
up to the line, though I didn't let onto it.
Callum just had a bored disinterested look
on his face. Good. Maybe I'd take him by surprise.
N. H. L. I tried to sweep the puck away from
the face off but Callum was too quick. I took
a defensive position. He cooly brought up
the puck to challenge me, leaving it out in
front of him for me to try to snatch it away.
I didn't take the bait, so he scooped the
puck off the floor of the field house. Seeing
my chance, I knocked his stick away, and seized
the puck. I was already taking off in the
other direction. I easily deked around the
rest of his team and deposited a shot in the
back of the net. 1-0.
I won the next face-off. I lobbed the puck
into an empty corner and chased it down. With
one man to beat, I deflected a shot off of
him and into the goal. 2-0.
Callum and I got back to the center circle.
He had that same bored look on his face. I
could tell if I won he was going to try to
play it off like he was never trying. But
he and I... and Kelsey for that matter, knew
he had gone undefeated in the other matches.
Plus, I had one more trick up my sleeve to
really put him in his place. I won the faceoff
again, this time I went right for Callum and
challenged him directly. Suddenly, he looked
surprised. Without looking down I sent the
puck in between his legs and dashed around
the side of him. As the puck got by him, and
safely into my possession I couldn't help
but crack a little bit of a smile with nothing
but an open path to the goal.
That's when I felt something hook my legs,
and I went crashing down onto my face as the
puck slid away into the corner. Callum. He
had reached back with his stick and intentionally
taken me out. Going face first into the ground
and slamming down my knee hurt, but I could
take that. But hearing Callum's cocky, defiant,
"oops" and seeing Kelsey unable to stop her
mouth from falling open in laughter set me
over. Ears burning, I got to my feet. Forgetting
about the puck, the game, and where I was,
I socked Callum straight in the jaw.
Before he could retaliate, our gym teacher
had yanked me away from the game and his face
was red as he screamed in my face. I didn't
hear any of it. My mind was still racing with
anger.
I found myself sitting outside the athletic
office before I'd started to calm down. Callum
was sitting on the far side of the room. I
should have been happy that he was getting
punished too, but he had this dumb smirk on
his face. Somehow I knew my parents were going
to be a lot more upset than his when all was
said and done. We sat in silence for a few
minutes before, an announcement came over
the intercom.
"Please pardon the interruption. Attention
students and staff. Please initiate internal
lockdown procedure at this time."
Now, normally I wouldn't have cared to participate
in a lockdown drill. But there was something
about this. Maybe that little hint of tremble
in the principal's voice. I think Callum felt
it too. Felt that it could be real.
"What should we do?" I asked him, breaking
the silence.
"Uhh I dunno."
It didn't seem like he was going to cooperate,
but then he added, "should we go look for
Mr. Dyke?"
Mr. Dyke was our gym teacher, a huge, hulking
mass of muscle, and probably the safest person
in the school to be around at a time like
this. I told Callum, "OK," and we headed back
into the halls by the locker room.
All of the lights had been shut off, so the
only source of light was coming from the door
at our end of the hall. All the way at the
opposite end, there's a closet. The door was
open, and someone was standing inside, facing
the inside of the closet. Callum looked like
he was about to call out, but I threw my hand
up as if to say, 'hold on'. He froze and eyed
me.
I wanted to make sure we weren't about to
willingly give ourselves up to the intruder.
We quietly walked in to get a better look
and see if we knew whoever was standing there.
*footsteps*
As my eyes adjusted to the dark a little,
and as we got closer, the person started to
take shape. The figure had wide shoulders,
big ears, and short hair--- it was Mr. Dyke,
our teacher! Only, he was just staring into
a dark closet, shoulders shaking... no, trembling...
Something was off.
"Mr. Dyke!" I called out. "We didn't know
what to do. Where should we..."
But I trailed off when I realized that he
was not listening. He was just... like...
petrified at the opening of the equipment
closet. His whole body was trembling, he was
breathing loudly and.... and he was whimpering.
"Mr. Dyke? ... Are you OK?"
No response. He didn't even acknowledge us.
Callum: "What the hell?"
"Come on. We need to go find another teacher."
We ran around the corner into the hall that
leads into the field house. One of the double
doors leading into the gym was cracked open
just slightly and I could see that the lights
were off in there as well, other than this
faint orange glow.
Callum: "Watch out."
There was some shattered glass on the floor.
I looked up to find someone had broken the
glass cases next to the fire alarm and removed
the fire extinguisher and axe. Yeah, it's
an old school. My heart dropped into my stomach.
This meant either one of two things. One,
that the threat was nearby and recently broke
in and retrieved the axe, or two, that someone
was scared enough to retrieve the axe for
self defense. Neither boded well for Callum
and I.
We went into the field house. The door swung
shut behind us.
*doorclose*
Callum: "Shoot."
He turned back and tried to open the door
we had just come through, but it was locked.
The orange colored glow I had seen was coming
from the scoreboard. There was a timer on
it, counting down with 1 minute and 33 seconds
remaining. There was also a score. It was
0-0, but in place of the team names reading
home and away, the team names read ARIS vs
KIDS.
We walked into the middle of the field house
and surveyed all around. The whole gym was
completely empty as far as I could tell. There
was one thought that sat in the back on my
mind though. There's this little room at the
top of the bleachers. It's where the scoreboard
control room is. From looking at the window,
I could tell the lights were off... but still...
the scoreboard was on.
Naturally, we wanted to get out of there.
There are several exits on each side of the
field house, but each one was locked. That
left us nothing to do but sit and wait for
the scoreboard timer to run out.
*BUZZER*
The shot clock buzzer blasted out our eardrums,
as an insane, like I can't even describe the
horror, crazy clown crashed up against the
scoreboard room window with a violent force.
This clown had a wild smile unlike anything
I had ever seen. The sound of that buzzer
may have hit me hard, but the feeling of despair
when I laid eyes on that clown... that monstrous
sight, hit me ten times harder. A crackle
came over the announcer speaker and circus
music, no I am not making this up, distorted,
broken sounding circus music started playing.
The scoreboard went off again. It now read
Aris: 1 Kids: 0 with no time remaining. The
door of the scoreboard room raucously flew
open and the clown, now holding an axe marched
it's big shoes into the doorway, the most
devilish grin on its face.
The clown bounded down the bleachers towards
us laughing hysterically as he did so. I glanced
over at Callum, wondering if we were going
with fight or flight. To my surprise he had
already taken off and left me in the dust!
I turned to book it, but for the second time
that day I felt my center of balance disrupt
as a sideways hockey puck rolled me off of
my feet and I slammed into the ground yet
again. At this point, my knee was throbbing.
I tried to get up as quickly as I could, but
the pain was too much and the clown was already
hovering over me; it's grin stretching unnaturally
from ear to ear as it swung it's axe high
in the air.
In those final moments, I found myself thinking
of some of my best and worst memories. My
birthday party at age seven. Getting in trouble
for sneaking alcohol with my friends. Opening
my Nintendo DS on Christmas morning. And more...
It wasn't like my life flashing before my
eyes, like people talk about. It was more
of a scramble to find a final memory to hold
onto. That's how I like to think of it. I
closed my eyes.
*clown screech*
My eyes shot back open to see what had caused
that horrible screech.
Callum: Hyah!
The clown had somehow been knocked back by
something. I looked up, it was Callum! He
was holding a hockey stick with the blade
turned away, using the butt end like a spear!
He jabbed at the clown's face knocking it
back.
Callum: "Get back!"
I gingerly rose to my feet. Callum motioned
to the floor, where he had already dropped
a second hockey stick. These sticks had pretty
flimsy plastic blades, but using the opposite
end like Callum, we'd be able to pack a little
bit of a punch.
The clown recomposed itself and approached
us again. It dragged the axe behind, leaving
an opening for us to try to make a quick attack.
But I knew better than to make a risky first
move. We waited until it was close enough
and let it take a wild unbalanced hack. I
felt my knee swelling as I jumped back out
of the way, but I was able to dodge the attack.
I went in first and took a low slash at the
waist, then Callum got in close -- dangerously
close, what was he doing? He reared back and
with one stabbing motion, lodged his stick
into the clown’s eye socket!
*Clown screech*
My jaw dropped as Callum kept hold of the
other end of the hockey stick while the clown
crashed down on it’s back and writhed for
a moment before going limp.
*clown writhing*
Callum yanked the stick out of the clown’s
head. Blood squirted everywhere. The clown’s
eye, which miraculously wasn’t crushed,
was ripped from its socket and bounced once
on the gym floor, still connected to the clown’s
head by a nerve like a ball and chain.
I honestly didn’t know what to say at this
point. My knee was throbbing, and I felt like
I was going to throw up. I limped over to
the first row of the bleachers and sat down.
Callum just squatted on the floor. We sat
quietly, catching our breath and waited for
someone to find us. It was maybe 10 minutes
before the school police officer came in to
clear the room. We gave the entire story.
He insisted that we visit the nurse, which
I welcomed openly. Callum probably didn’t
need to checked out, but he went along anyway
-- figuring it was better than going back
to the office, though our little gym class
fight didn’t seem like such a big deal now.
The school nurse doesn’t have a ton of tools
at her disposal -- I was given an ice pack
for my knee and told to relax until the cops
showed up. While we waited, I apologized to
Callum for socking him in the face earlier,
and he told me he felt bad about his egregious
penalty as well. He said maybe he’d join
us for a little driveway hockey sometime and
he’d even let me have a penalty shot whenever
he does.
I told him that was fair, but before he could
respond, another announcement came over the
intercom, only… it’s wasn’t the all-clear that
I had expected.
"Attention all students and staff. You are
to remain in internal lockdown at this time.
Please ensure ALL rooms are secure.”
The end of the announcement brought that uncomfortable
silence I had become all too familiar with
back into the room. The nurse went over and
locked the door. What was going on? Was there
a second intruder in the school? Normally
during a lockdown, we’d have to get against
the wall and hide on the ground away from
the windows. However, there were no windows
in the nurse’s office so we just stayed
where we were and remained silent.
*footsteps*
There were footsteps approaching down the
hall. I heard echoed screams coming from another
classroom. At least this time we were behind
a locked door. The steps continued to approach,
until the stopped in front of our door. I
held my breath.
*rattle*
The person standing outside gave a hard tug
on our doorknob. It seemed like forever…
but realistically, it was a few more seconds
until the footsteps continued down the hall,
onto the next room. I let out a sigh of relief.
About 30 minutes later, we would find out
the reason for the second announcement from
the police chief, who came to visit us at
the nurse’s office. After the school police
officer sent us on our way, he investigated
the clown, who appeared to be dead. He then
got word that the SWAT team had arrived, and
went to go touch base them. When they returned
to the field house and turned on the lights,
the body of the clown was no longer there.
At that point, they made the second announcement,
making sure students and teachers did not
think that it was safe to come out of the
lockdown procedures. They had to re-clear
every single room, then after a meeting with
the administration staff, they finally decided
they had done everything they could do, and
finally gave the all-clear.
There had been a couple of other clown attacks
at schools over the last couple years, so,
Callum and I were questioned heavily about
the incident. However, as you can imagine,
there were moments that caused them to roll
their eyes; they clearly didn’t believe
some of the more outlandish details. I’m
afraid that may have caused the validity of
our accounts to be thrown into question, but
everything in this story is the truth, and
I’ve got Callum to back me up on that.
But I let them know not to just take our word
for it.
“Go find those hockey sticks we had used
to fend off the clown,” I told them. Of
course, they already had taken those in for
evidence, there was just one problem.
Some time over the next couple of weeks, they
ran tests on the DNA left behind on the sticks,
which matched the DNA of someone who had been
in a high security prison since 2016 and was
still there today. Obviously, I didn’t know
how this was possible, and they were coming
at me like I had planted this guy’s DNA
there, like this whole ordeal was some kind
of stupid prank we had pulled. I couldn’t
believe the way they were talking to me. So,
that was pretty much the end of that… but
unfortunately, it wasn’t the end of this
nightmare.
There is one kind of cool thing about being
the victim of a lockdown attack. It got me
a lot of attention at school. For the next
two weeks, everyone wanted to hear my story…
and let’s just say I got pretty good retelling
my dramatic account for any of the cute girls
who asked me about it. Unfortunately, I was
never able to score that date with Kelsey
from gym class, but I had no shortage of female
attention.
One night I was walking home this girl -- I
think her name was Ashley. We were walking
because I didn’t have my license yet. We
walked by this alley, and out of the corner
of my eye, I see someone standing there, staring
down the alley. Now... this next part happened
pretty fast… and I’m still a little bit
unsure about it. I turned my head, and just
before we walked past the alley, I catch a
brief glimpse of... the clown. The clown from
that day. Just standing there in the alley
-- one eye staring at me and the other eye
just hanging down out of it’s socket. My
heart FLIPPED.This can’t be happening. It
was over. Ashley, or whatever her name was,
stopped walking and asked me if I was OK.
I looked back, and… it was just an empty
alley. Nowhere to even hide. What was going
on? Was my mind playing tricks on me? Is this
was PTSD is like? I asked her if she saw anything,
and she said no, but she was standing on the
other side of me, she couldn’t have…
*sigh*
Not wanting to look like a pussy in front
of my date I acted as if I had shrugged it
off and changed the subject. But for the rest
of that night, I couldn’t get the sound
of that clown’s laughter out of my head.
In fact, I really can’t say with certainty
that I ever will.
Thanks for listening to Al Dente Creepypasta.
Your total for this video is $1 and 33¢ but
if you like this video right now, I’ll waive
that fee and give you everything you just
listened to absolutely free. Guest narrators
today include After Dark Analysis, and the
music was scored by OST Maker. Today’s video
is brought to you by the CZsWorld merch store,
where you can pick up the new My Life Is A
Horror Movie Merch. Check out these videos
for other Creepy Clown School Lockdown incidents
-- and remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one. Assuming we both survive.